why is no one talking about this hello
allison felix becomes most decorated
athlete in championship history
track and field is not that popular in
the united states we get some love every
now and then every four years
we're an underrated sport comes with the
territory hey i'm allison felix six time
olympic gold medalist
i'm here to answer your questions on
twitter this is track support
[Music]
at just that purple track and field
question how do you run a 400 meter dash
properly this is a great question the
400 meters
is one of the hardest events in track
and field it doesn't matter
how fast you run it or how slow you run
it you are going to be in pain
at the end the best way to do it is to
be able to come out
at a percentage of your top speed
you don't want to run all out for the
first 200 meters because you have to be
able to last
and then you want to save something to
be able to kick home with
and that's the hard part a lot of that
it comes from your training you know
have you done the work or have you not
if you have
you should be strong you should be able
to carry that pace on home if you
haven't you might need to do some more
base work
to be able to handle that speed
endurance and to be able to handle
you know that amount of time sprinting
at track nation
why do sprinters and distance runners
dislike each other
that's a good question i don't know
sprinters typically
they say i don't know sometimes we're
described as being like
divas and kind of full of ourselves i
think distance runners are
seen as more like no workhorses
i don't believe this like i have a lot
of great friends who are distance
runners
you know we all we're all track nation
right at the only jayla
ass the 400 is a painful race but the
butt cramp after
lord it's even worse jayla i agree with
you
a thousand percent we in track and field
we call it the booty lock like it's just
it's awful and there's really no no way
around it
when you run the 400 there's like a
build up of lactic acid in your legs it
kind of like paralyzes you like you
can't really do anything
and so a lot of people tell you you got
gotta keep moving you gotta
stand up you gotta kind of shake out
your legs i don't really think any of it
works you just have to kind of like
get through it at usatf how are olympic
relay teams determined
top four finishers in the individual
event final that's not how relays are
determined
there's a lot of politics that go into
you know
creating any relay there's four members
of the relay two are running a straight
and two are running a curve so you might
have the four
fastest but they may not be the fastest
in those
positions you know so if you have
someone who runs a straight really fast
but you also have two other people who
do that really well you only need two
for the relay
that might bump someone out and someone
who's a great starter and who has
really great speed on the turn might get
put in there
you know we go to relay camp and we work
out all different combinations
you know you got to have alternates in
case someone gets injured
and you just got to kind of be ready for
anything sometimes it's the last minute
and the whole team changes
it's just kind of the nature of running
a relay at alex
dean asks how do sprinters gain so much
speed
a lot of speed is gained in the weight
room from plyometrics
from olympic lifts doing things with
your own body weight and also
being able to apply that strength onto
the track so a lot of
sled and bringing that that weight into
motion and that's how you really
gain speed and get faster working on
acceleration
a lot of it is coming out of the blocks
it's a lot about angles it's
biomechanics
really making sure you're at the perfect
angle for your leg length for your body
type
kind of like an airplane when you're
taking off i'm not all the way there yet
you know something that
constantly working on but it's all about
you know falling
and being able to recover at d west dock
i'm confused
why do sprinters wear half sleeves
aerodynamics you actually wear
like half sleeves or calf sleeves for me
i have
bad shin splints and actually the
compression helps them
i think some people like the way it
looks at daniel peak
asks okay so here's a question why is
there not
a four by one olympic relay event where
two runners are men and two are women in
each team
i think that the answer to this is just
the speed
that men and women are going are so
different in the 4x4
the incoming runner holds up the baton
kind of like a torch the outgoing runner
reaches back to receive the baton in the
4x1
it's a blind exchange the outgoing
runner stays with their head
forward and they just throw their hand
back they never look back
and so it's a completely blind pass that
has to happen
seamlessly because the two runners are
running both at their top speed
so it's all about a flawless exchange
because obviously
you cannot drop the baton you got to get
it right though or it's going to be
dangerous
you can't have guys like mowing the
other runners down
so it's really a timing thing but i
don't think it's impossible
at tick my sweet
track is like the only sport i know that
people can be decked out in jewelry like
wtf
what is the point of trying to be fancy
people people in track and field are
typically
all wearing the same uniform and they
want to differentiate themselves
jewelry is a way where people can stand
out so track people
they they like to floss sometimes i
agree
sometimes it's extra but you know
people gotta get in where you can at
kiki
cerebrum how do you qualify for the
olympics
okay you qualify for the olympics by
running
an olympic trial standard so basically
there's a time that you have to run
to get invited to the olympic trials so
there's typically three rounds to each
race
the prelim the semi and the final you
have to be on that final day you have to
be top three
from the united states we take three
people in most events
and that's how you qualify as long as
you've run fast enough an olympic
standard
then you are on the team at dave blogger
asks
why do sprinters seem to have large
upper bodies and distance runners are
slim from head to toe
do you use your arms more in sprinting
so in sprinting
it's pretty much a more powerful race
you know you need
more power to get through it it's
ballistic speed you know it's the
fastest that you can go it's why we
spend a lot of time in the weight room
it's what's really getting you down
the track i think strength it looks a
lot of different ways
and typically you know we do think of it
in that way but it's not always the case
distance runners they can't carry that
muscle around you know they have to run
for such a long amount of time you know
cover a lot of distance
they really have to be lean and they
have to be they can't carry all that
extra weight so that's why
you'll see those distance runners be a
lot lighter and a much smaller build
at big game james 36
got a question what's a good time to run
in the 40.
it's really like a football you know
thing
low fours four three if you're really
good
at david o'leary nine what's the best
lane to be in while running the 400.
the best lane to be in when running the
400 is gonna be
in the middle of the track lanes four
five and six are typically in every
track those are usually
the ideal lanes but the thing is it's
400 meters no matter what lane you're in
but for some reason us runners we like
to be in the middle
it's nice to be able to see you know
your competitors and have a gauge
but it's funny we all train out of lane
one but for some reason we never want to
be in it in
the actual race at plumpernickel
asks question for runners does anyone
feel nauseous post run
how can one deal with it this is a new
thing for me and it's probably linked to
loss of electrolytes
yeah it's not unusual to feel nauseous
post run make sure
that you're fueled properly so make sure
you eat make sure
you know you have enough to get you
through whatever your workout is
and also if you're just getting back
into the swing of things or you're a new
runner you might just have to build up a
little bit
i mean there's still workouts to this
day where i'm throwing up afterwards
and it's just kind of a part of it you
know if you're challenging your body to
go past its normal limits then sometimes
you can have that reaction
at faubles fables hey running twitter
i'm almost embarrassed to ask what might
be a foolish question
but i'm finally getting back into
running again after a hiatus
is there a my body just plain feels
broken stage
to a running rebuild yeah
i feel you on this one after you haven't
ran for a long time
it is really hard to get back into the
swing of things you've got to be kind to
yourself i
don't understand why it takes like one
week to get out of shape
but months on end to get in shape but
it's a thing you'll get through it
it doesn't feel pleasant you can take
ice baths you can go to cryo you can
foam roll
you can use all the little tools to kind
of give your legs some life
make sure you rest but yeah it gets
better at official malik
asks how does anyone manage to look good
while running i can't even look decent
matter of fact i look like a chimpanzee
who managed to set himself
loose from the zoo smh it's hard to look
good while running i think you either
have it or you don't i think this is
something you're either born with or
you're not
you know a lot of times when you're
running you feel like you need to be
very intense
and that's going to get you from point a
to b the fastest
you're trying to muscle through and
you're just like pumping your arms
really hard and
you're all over the place i tell people
to relax
take a breath and realize that you don't
have to be so tense
you know you also probably tend to look
a bit better
as well but it really it helps you get
from a to b
faster at coach diggs asks why do
sprinters tend to start with their left
foot by default
i think typically sprinters start with
whatever foot a coach told them
way back in some day typically you start
with your strongest foot
and just take some experience to find
out what's the right foot for you
bro what's the best breathing technique
for running you really want to make sure
that you
are breathing while you're running
definitely in the sprints a lot of
people try to just hold their breath
or they don't really think about it so
you want to make sure that you're taking
you know nice deep breaths especially
when you're in those blocks you're about
to come out
but you don't want to just be constantly
thinking about it and taking away from
your technique and all of that stuff so
you want to focus on it but more so in
practice when you get to the races
you want to just let it flow naturally
at underscore
tommy wamey how do runners out there
balance lifting and running
i try hard not to run right after
lifting but it's hard not to sometimes
due to timing
for me i like to get my workout in first
on the track
and then i go to the weight room but
there are some days where i reverse it
i think it's basically about balancing
whichever comes first so if you're gonna
lift first
you need to adjust it in a way where
you're not doing too much
like not too much legs not too much
really heavy work if you're going
straight to run afterwards and so just
making those little adjustments are
going to allow so that you don't have an
injury and you don't have to take time
off
but just being smart you know if you
have a day where you lift heavy then you
might want to adjust your running
workout and scale back a little bit
at tesla's the future questions for
runners when i run
my shins hurt is it my shoes what do you
suggest
shin splints are a problem for a lot of
runners i myself
suffer from very severe shin splints a
lot of
shin splints come from the surface that
you run on if you do have shin splints
you want to run
on a softer surface like if you can run
on grass
it's great you want to avoid roads hard
trails with
uneven surfaces even some tracks are
really difficult because they can be
really hard so you want to run on softer
surfaces
to kind of give those shins a break you
can ice them afterwards with like an ice
massage take a paper cup freeze it with
water
tear off the sides and just rub it up
and down your shins
it feels really amazing after a hard
workout
at ian underscore p underscore brazier
how do runners deal with the post race
come down you gotta have a
proper kind of like cool down you don't
want to just like stop running and then
like get in your car and go home
you wanna like make sure that your heart
rate gradually
comes down like jogging for a few
minutes afterwards
you know getting some nice stretching in
you just want to make sure that you're
not abruptly just
you know stopping all movement and it's
just good to get in that routine so
whatever that routine is for you you
know even if you're walking a little bit
that's still good at run all day let's
settle this
which is the best track event that's
easy the 200 meters
at underscore rob g why do sprinters
gotta run long distance in practice
i feel you i don't understand why either
i mean i guess we need the base
but as a sprinter i am not a fan if i
cross the point where i started
it just doesn't make sense at brittley h
asks is allison felix the beyonce of
track and field
that's funny i i have no idea i don't
think i'm the beyonce of track and field
i've been around for a long time so i
don't know if that qualifies me
okay the second part of the question if
that's the case which 4x1 team is
the destiny's child so destiny's child
would definitely be the world record
setting 4x1
which would be myself carmelita jetter
bianca knight
and tiana madison we had great chemistry
it was just like so light and effortless
when we went out
in 2012 to set the world record and so
it's got to be
us well that was the last question i had
a lot of fun answering those for you
guys some really good ones and
some pretty funny ones that's it for me